die jungen gibt immer dieses case solche
aufmachen weil die heute in florida und
herzstück haben bei einem neuen video ja
heute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
das heutige video also ich sag mal so
normalerweise sind meine videos vor
geplant bis so nächsten monat aber das
video heute also ich wusste heute morgen
nicht dass ich dieses video dreh bei den
zuschauer hat mir danach beschränkte er
alex tdi hat jetzt erste nicht so
hellberg de facto also diesen laden
kennt ja wahrscheinlich oder kennt ja
die meisten von euch das ist so ein
rahmen schlagen so da gibt so ganz
finalen euro produkte und die haben
jetzt wohl airports bzw
ja an sich ich sag mal so wenn ich das
jetzt hier sehr inspiriert von airports
ich bin dann direkt hingefahren ich bin
dann direkt hin gefahren und wollte
schauen ob die das wirklich auch hier
haben oder ob man das im internet
bestellen muss keine ahnung und bin
heute hier die straße runter irgendwann
kommt ein teddy und haben nachgefragt
weil ich nicht gefunden habe und die
verkäuferin wusste sofort was ich meine
ich glaube die gibt es erst seit heute
oder gestern und ja wir setzen uns mal
hin ich habe einfach bei tde so eine art
wenn du was sagst du was hast du für bis
heute
fünf euro mehr 9 euro mehr
15 15 euro kosten und was mir direkt
aufgefallen ist hier steht auf tvs drauf
in ear kopfhörer
ich habe allerdings bis jetzt noch keine
genauere bezeichnung ermitteln können
also was ist genau ist bei sind weil wir
haben ja als letztes die tws 200
getestet sind auch am ende alle verlinkt
das waren bis jetzt die besten
die haben am besten abgeschnitten und
ich bin mal gespannt klar und im case an
sich das also ich weiß auch nicht was
sie sich dabei dachten aber nicht sein
denn zunächst sieht aus wie eine
mülltonne aber die airports an sich
finde ich ganz in ordnung die sind
brutal fett oder schon ich bin mal auf
den sound gespannt wer mehr kann man
dazu eigentlich sagen aber man muss halt
auch ganz klar sagen ist schon schlauer
mut weil airports sind so in der jugend
folge hat und welche eltern wollen denn
der 180 euro dafür ausgeben dann gehe
die in theley und bringen ihren
zehnjährigen sohn so was man als kind
wird hätte sowas bekommen du hattest
deine eltern gehabt ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht mal gecheckt aber
nicht also ich glaube schon so die kv
auf dem schulhof wenn du so ein case
dabei hat das aber auch irgendwie
traurig so ich meine es kann sich halt
nicht jeder für 180 euro kopfhörer
natürlich aber dann so zu machen ja ich
weiß auch nicht also ich kann ihnen ein
beispiel nennen sowie das wird zu tragen
dem thema abschweifen
aber ich habe früher mal mit meinen
gameboy so dieses dingen habe ich glaube
ich mit 7 bekommen zu weihnachten und
ich habe mich zwei jahre lang habe ich
irgendwie so ein anderes ding gehabt das
hat mir mein vater geschenkt und ich
dachte halt deswegen gameboy und es war
kein geld so irgendwie so ein
ich weiß nicht dass er da irgendwo
türkei hergestellt das dürfte keiner das
krasse der zeit wenn die besser wird die
höchstens getestet haben sich selber vor
das verstehe ich auch nie warum gibt es
solche verpacken und dann schneidet man
sich der folgen länder hat was drauf
hält das geht doch trotzdem kaputt was
das publikum war und hier haben jetzt
ich glaube die allererste airport sich
gepasst deshalb von bush die hatten auch
ein android kabel und die haben wir
jetzt wieder in die jungen wirklich mal
dieses case sich aufmachen und er
trotzdem größer als mein finger alter
[Musik]
nach die marke passen die wirbellosen
schließt sich das ist das muss auch so
einen posten so so jetzt lebt
anscheinend nicht mit allen naja weiß
worauf ich jetzt mal richtig gespannt
bin wenn ich jetzt gleich mit meinem
handy connect was dann da kommt jetzt
stell dir vor da kommt halt auch so
wirklich so wie viel prozent das case
geladen sind so viel prozent die
kopfhörer geladen sind das glaube ich
nicht
bei bis jetzt hatten die zwölf tws die
haben geht zum euro gekostet und ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher klar wenn der sound
ist gleich umwerfend ist nämlich dass
vielleicht noch mal zurück aber holt
euch lieber die leute also sowas hier
sorry das ist ja bevor er zum sound test
kommen würde ich sagen wir vergleichen
noch einmal die kopfhörer miteinander
inwiefern die sich mit dem original
ähneln also ich kann man hier aber auch
zur verteidigung sagen die werden gar
nicht als airports sex angeboten sondern
als bluetooth kopfhörer das ist ja bei
diesem ganzen fakes man im internet
findet anders weist die wollen ja
möglichst nah am apple gerät sein und
hier vorne haben wir das original hinten
die kehdinger ich frage mich gibt immer
die ohrmuschel das passt doch gar nicht
in meinen augen ab oder jetzt mal ohne
spaß ich probiere das mal schütteln mein
kopf getroffen
danach belaufen die bleiben drin wären
drin also hätte ich nicht gedacht also
ich weiß die sind nicht so richtig im
ohr die sind dann ist es ja so gebündelt
so in verschiedene werbung sage ich mal
die sind so ein zweites leben
biologe als herren dann gut wenn jetzt
versteht was ich meine
ok dann wollen wir jetzt mal connect und
würde ich sagen oder oder wasserkontakt
wenig wachs vorhandene beschreibung weil
wir noch bei sogar auf deutsch
es ist ja ganz gut aber ich glaube nicht
juni ist das schott kummer also wirklich
die zwölf tws eine milliarde mal besser
und für sowas dann 15 euro das ist eine
frechheit
nicht oder nicht finde ich dir jetzt
wohl was er tun und lassen können damals
ich will doch die bedienungsanleitung
lesen hier steht jetzt an die heißen tee
wsj gemerkt man muss hier oben die taste
drücken und nicht an dem case das ja
blöd das müsste es leicht blinken halt
mal wo ich bitte ja ich halte euch so
und jetzt bitte verbinden trocknen
fehlgeschlagen hast du beide online das
ist mir jetzt schon so kompliziert
connected connected besteht immer noch
komplett fehl geschlagen haben man sieht
ja musik anmachen
ich bin ich ahne böses ganz böses ist
nicht verbunden
69 stunden später beide ja ok keine
ahnung warum das jetzt geklappt hat aber
es hat geklappt
ich weiß was das problem ist man kann
die man sieht gar nicht mehr richtig
vielleicht ist das der grund das hört
sich so so voll ist schwierig zu
beschreiben es hört sich einfach
brutaler plastik und metall gilt noch
bis jetzt ist in thron folgen die ganze
zeit manchmal blau das bin zwischendurch
glaubt was sagst du die level von die
letztes jahr noch letzte mal besser als
jeden fall ja also dass ich nicht nicht
1000% scheiße aber es klingt nicht nach
guter musik was du auch nur an hass und
wenn nicht dann das hier noch dazu sehr
also weißt du was wir nie getestet haben
bei den ganzen letzten ob die verbindung
ab packt wenn man ein bisschen weg geht
weil bei den airports die recht lange
also ich kann eine ganze kiste der
stetig wachsenden nick mit ja ich mich
berufen die künftig machen ja über
welche die custom überdies hast du es
das mikro eingestellt über das über die
airports sieht man richtig laut dass der
putz
okay das ist echt gut also das geht echt
klar ja mega das war echt toll
also ich fand es echt gut also fast
einmal kurz zusammen
optisch gesehen in der klasse 6 sound
also jetzt mal nach schulnoten bewertet
sound so ein ausreichend vielleicht der
ausreichend - mikrofon qualität hast du
gesagt okay also weil ordnung und des
tanzes ja auch weiß deswegen ja aber das
wichtigste ist ja der sound und der
schweiz halt rein es kauft euch die 12
tb erst für 14 euro bis jetzt also muss
man sagen oder er legt noch zehn euro
obendrauf und holt euch die 200 tws das
war bis jetzt die besten wir haben
demnächst noch die 1000 apps welche wohl
aktuell der absolute renner sein sollen
ob das stimmt werden wir sehen ansonsten
hat es mich gefreut auch die sicher zu
testen aber für mich durch gefallen also
jetzt ja nicht also dann
damit kann sich das schlüsselressort
dass irgendwelche ja und und an die
etwas jüngeren wenn ihr die habt seid
nicht traurig oder so es ist auf jeden
fall in ordnung so also ich will jetzt
keine schlecht reden oder so für den
preis kann man nicht meckern
aber wie gesagt ich lege auch die 200
tws ans herz die sind deutlich besser
kosten zehn euro mehr aber dann macht da
nichts mit falsch bevor ich es vergesse
die werden natürlich hier auf meinem
instagram verlost weil ich damit
überhaupt nichts anfangen kann ist kann
ja sein dass leute draußen die gerne
hätten deswegen jackman ist ab da post
sich die irgendwann das sorry wir müssen
auch die story antworten dann nimmt
geteilt der gewinner wird irgendwann
angeschrieben ansonsten war es aus kanal
abonnieren
ihr könnt mir auch gerne weitere
airports die ich testen solle airport
felix bei instagram treiber oder hier in
die kommentare
video ideen auch mal sehr gerne in die
kommentare wir sehen uns morgen wieder
gibt es ein neues video
[Musik]